well here we are new studio buddy new
studio dig it
i love it cause daddy just shows up
daddy just she just shows up
i want to help but you don't i don't
need your help yeah you don't need my
put on on basically the studio
no because i'm not going to be like well
i think that color doesn't work it's
just not my
thing this is texture color i wish it
was this was the inspiration from chin
and brian johnson put it together but me
and chen had this
idea and then brian johnson ran with it
built it all by hand
i'd say brian johnson's a monster i love
it making me my graphic right now
uh i'm now now july
oh you're gonna do dates july 29th i
won't be around
for the entire 29th because i gotta
leave in the morning
because i got to drive to the inland
empire to the ontario improv so i'm
going to leave at
6 00 a.m once i get there i'm kidding
but you know it just takes
oh because have you ever made it there
have you ever made it from i would
rather
fly to new york
ontario improv i gotta you gotta leave
three hours
it's gonna take three hours to get there
it takes three hours three hours see
how long see how long this [ __ ] la
see how long what is the mileage between
venice and the ontario improv
let me see what it is drive into
calabasas for daddy
i loved it i i go up to appreciate yeah
it's a nice drive i don't know
i always take topanga i love it and i
can take company or malibu canyon you
can get here
i i go i go malibu ken yeah it's nice oh
it's [ __ ] beautiful
for three and a half years yeah it's a
lot what's that three and a half years
taking that
route that's awesome to santa monica
it's a long time that's been done and
that's daddy's trinity now it's my turn
i don't mind
you did all this i love this studio and
and okay it's only an hour 27 right now
brian
it's only an hour 27 so that's 59 miles
and it's gonna take
when on well if you leave in rush hour
like if you leave at three
even then what am i but then i gotta
hang out so okay so i'll leave it three
i get there at five my show doesn't
start at eight i'm not on stage till 8
30. it's almost better to leave at six
it's almost it's a risk low risk but i'm
known for taking risks have bill burr
flying a helicopter
i would spend good money
you mean all your money you make that
weekend on one trip to and by helicopter
to avoid traffic there's also nothing to
do with that zero i love the people
i love the i love clubs in the country
100 the the whole inland power
they come to laugh i love you you missed
a good time at the haha my first time
doing sets there you've done sessions
i've done sets there for many years
i've never done sets there only done set
you know uh ice house
i'm gonna do it i like it it's great
yeah great crowds great room
guy pulled his dick out guy pulled his
dick out
obviously on drugs or not all there ah
definitely wasn't alcohol because they
because the security said when we let
him in he was normal dude he must took
something because he went from zero to a
hundred did some peeing
did somebody dude he pissed on a group
of mexicans that didn't appreciate it
you're not getting thick mexicans too
you're not gonna get away with that no
mexicans aren't gonna like they
they beat the [ __ ] out of them yeah
rightfully so now big job was ready to
go as well
this guy had his hands full dude
the guy seems like he clearly wasn't all
there he thought he was in you know what
happens
he probably thought he was in the
bathroom and he pulled i just think he
was
so drugged up he just pulled his dick
out there his girl was also [ __ ] up
really sometimes though you know [ __ ]
can happen where you're disoriented you
have a brain
i don't think so no i've never done that
i'm trying to be a comedy show
no i'm saying that you can like i know
somebody who had dementia and they're
young
and they took their pants off in the
restaurant that'd be the exception this
guy was [ __ ] up on drugs
and dude but he pissed on the wrong look
you're my big hand
my big boyfriend was about to beat the
show now the cops came and they're like
i mean what do you want to do like
what do you what do you want to do what
you do is you go this is why you have to
have
bouncers in your comedy clubs and i've
done
comedy clubs where there weren't any
boundaries too st louis actually had a
problem
no security really no you're now your
security it was a nightmare jay shopless
he's pretty good jay's [ __ ] my boy he's
like my number one fan he looks like one
third in [ __ ] the strongest fan
contest and jay shobb and they hemmed
this [ __ ] guy up
okay chrissy chrissy d was staying in
the back
he's from new york and i thought he'd no
chrissy chrissy d stayed in the back
he'll stay in the back he'll avoid the
comic but you get the couple thick boys
who get in there and they get under his
arms you got to get under your arms you
get you get you get your
hands this part of your hand you got
thrown in the back thrown out the back
like a like you know in the movies when
they throw a guy out of the saloon or
something that's why
he got thrown to the ground i had a i
had a lot of dick was out
i was in the entire time i was in philly
i had a large drunk man
grabbed me about the the upper ribs and
his
the blade of his hand was under my my
armpits
and he and he had me there and he goes
like this he goes i liked what you did
and i couldn't really move he had me all
big guy he big guy he had me all like
kind of like like a little toddler like
a little toddler
just shaking me about yeah and i and i
was like and i
felt very violated this this guy got
dealt with this guy
because remember he pissed on mexicans
too so the mexicans weren't happy
yeah well how do you do middle i mean 10
minutes into the act
start and i just hear she goes what the
[ __ ]
what in the [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa whoa
calm down i'm gonna choose no i'm sorry
we're such big fans we've been waiting
for this
she doesn't know this guy's dick is out
man i go his dick's out right now
she goes yes look he's peeing he pissed
on my shoe oh no
and then afterwards we get done like
what the [ __ ] and then christy
was like that was great man i've been in
comedy for [ __ ] ever i've never seen
that that was great
i look at comic did you get that kyle's
like i got that
like holy [ __ ] we got this on tape he
looked like he was smiling and just
standing there right he looked like just
sitting there like yeah yeah
there's not much you can do huh when a
guy's that out of it and just gone
i mean i did the first thing that you
and i would just did was a big dick
my first i went was a big dick yeah big
dick no one's gonna complain yeah get a
big old
piece out start peeing everyone's like
all right that's cool wow small dick we
can't have
a little pointer did anyone see the dick
i mean jay had to apprehend him but it
was dark
it's hard to apprehend that's how you
know it's not a big dick though this big
date's going to shine no matter what you
come you come up from behind
make sure you don't get the pee pee on
you yeah you can't have any
pee pee on you we talked to people after
they were cool we got we got
it did they mop it up yeah yeah
they mopped it up they put caution signs
and they relocate the people
and this is where i [ __ ] up they
relocated the people and they're
actually talking about the
trauma they just went through yeah but i
thought they were talking to my act so
then i lit
them up and then after the show like
dude we
we weren't talking we we got real i was
like i'm so sorry
yeah i am so sorry yeah rough night for
them
that's a tough one that's like my friend
who did a broadway play
and said you got to keep it down in the
middle of the play because the guy was
making noise
and the guy was on a respirator he was a
paraplegic quadriplegic
so his machine was going he goes are you
done over there
but you do got to keep it down got to
keep it down can we just
sir it's my iron lung i know but then
can't see the front row dude
he was actually no he was back oh it
must have been loudly loud right
it's a little loud and what are you
gonna do in that situation when you're
hearing
you can't be like hey keep your iron
line then it's gonna make a scene if
he's like sorry
and [ __ ] yeah can you die for yeah
hey man can you not come to you not
gonna do that
i took oh i saw space jam this weekend
took the entire sea space jam
you know what's weird is he was like oh
dad i want to see space jam
and i'm like dude i'll show you [ __ ]
space jam i was gonna show them the
jordan one we all grew up on
but he loves lebron like him and his
little friend were playing basketball
the other day
and you know how we used to when we were
kids michael jordan or you know people
kobe
i hear tiger go lebron james i'm like
holy [ __ ] boy
that's his jordan that's insane dude
so he wanted to see the movie i was
taking the movie and i i don't like
lebron anymore
for a variety of reasons but i was like
all right so i went in with a negative
attitude it was
[ __ ] good dude and he was good wasn't
he no no no not at all
he was when he was in the beginning he's
acting like oh this can be a [ __ ]
disaster
yeah but then he's only in it for like
you know the first 10 minutes and then
he's in cartoon world
so it's just his voice which is great
when he's animated it's fantastic
right dude it's a good [ __ ] movie it
is it was really good
dude and it's two hours long i was like
way too long for a kid movie tiger's not
gonna like this and he
he loved it really he loved it halfway
through you know
i got a big bag of skittles i'm like
dude don't eat all those you can get
sick i'm telling you you get sick
i like him to learn i don't want to just
tell him he needs to learn that's right
so i see him keep eating them like i'm
telling you do you get [ __ ] sick you
haven't eat lunch you get that's too
much sugar
he keeps eating them keeps eating them
halfway through them he goes dad i don't
feel good i'm like i
[ __ ] told you dude i was like what do
you want to do he's the best way to
learn he's like yeah
whatever he's cute the movie's so good
he forgets about it we're walking out
he starts going i go dude i [ __ ] told
you
i said why you gotta take a piss for me
and throw up do it in the bathroom so we
walk in there and whenever like
if somebody blows up a bathroom he like
has an ill reaction to it
he'll just start gagging so we're
walking there's someone some
dude blew it the [ __ ] up we walk in he
goes look dad we gotta get outta here i
go i gotta take a piss dude so just
hang tight he's going look i know don't
you throw up there's all this feeling i
go don't throw up
i'm peeing so hard i'm like dude just
hold it he keeps going look
dude sure enough just like big daddy
[Music]
rainbow you're like that yeah i'm like
that rainbow throw up
all over the bathroom and i go okay
let's get the [ __ ] oh yeah you gotta
i don't have a mop
we get and then we gotta drop something
there we get in the cargo you feel
bigger i feel so much better i'm like
probably betty threw all that up he goes
dad do we have to go back and clean i go
no tiger
some poor soul who's getting paid
minimum wage has to go in there now
and clean up your [ __ ] mess did i
tell you about my son where we were
walking the dog and you find things out
about your kids
uh my son uh he was into vampires
and i said well the best movie is the is
gary oldman and dracula
you got to see this oh too old and he
finds out where he
you know where he's he becomes a vampire
by renouncing god
i show him the scene where the the
statues start to cry because he's
because meat has been killed
and the statues start to cry and then
there's blood everywhere and he drinks
the blood
and my son story gagging well my son it
was on youtube and what i didn't realize
is some people
can't do that some my son goes oh
no i i just remember he goes that's
disgusting
ah and then we're walking and he's he's
holding his stomach he's dramatic he's
like an actor
he's going ah i can't come on come on
come on he said i can't
well he i look at his face and i go well
you're sheet white
you're she white made him sick and he
starts to pass out
my son from the blood my son like some
people can't see blood they pass
out some people are like that that's
what he has i don't give a [ __ ] i had
that me neither
but his his grandfather has that not my
dad but he's here yeah so
it's hereditary it is so so and i had a
girlfriend like that i'm like that if i
see [ __ ]
oh really yeah you faint or you just
i'll gag
well yeah yeah i don't like [ __ ] i like
if they're [ __ ] like they're you know
like my girl does well with like boston
or says a blowout diaper she but you
gotta change this one like oh my god
that's terrible i'll change them
oh you're really literally a dude i
can't i don't gag
but i realized that my son couldn't
handle so i had to carry him home
i felt so bad cause i thought he was
[ __ ] around so i come come on let's
go out of all the
[ __ ] vampire movies you show them
that one from the 1950s i felt terrible
no it was from the 80s or 90s get
younger dude it was like ninety
didn't show them like interview with the
vampire lost boys i don't know man
i just remember that one scene where
he's like renouncing god and i was like
you got to see this and i was like wrong
there's so many ones there's blood
everywhere everywhere and he drinks the
blood and that sent him over the edge he
was like uh dude i'll tell you what like
you shouldn't do with a five-year-old
you know
everyone's like man you somewhat watch
rick and morty i'm like yeah
he doesn't get a lot of it's fine the
last episode on season five
[ __ ] uh morty there's like
so if you've never seen the show morty's
mom is a veterinarian yeah and so
there's a machine
where they melt the horses they get the
semen out and morty's going he's like
mom let's get out of here
and there's a machine and he goes what's
this he puts his hand in he's like oh
that's a warm hole
and so he [ __ ] the machine and then his
semen
it goes into the horse semen well rick
is like oh i'm doing this
thing where i take the semen and i do
blah blah blah and there's
not for kids here all of this is not for
kids none of it so there's these giant
sperm things in it it's
well and he goes dad why can't we watch
the new rick and morty because i watched
the night before to make sure he can
watch it
i watch like you can't see that one oh
and then he goes dad let's watch it oh
dude didn't record it
he was in recording you believe that
didn't record it dude so we'll we'll
watch next week so hopefully
last night's was at least somewhat not
have to deal with [ __ ] come
on rick and morty show up in the new
space jam
oh really they're getting big time they
have a lot of great cameos in the new
space jam
like a lot have you seen it yeah game of
thrones
it's all warner game of thrones i'll do
you one on that
my daughter's 12 she's into fantasy
novels she's read all the fantasy novels
she read game of thrones
she didn't read that but i said you need
to watch game of thrones
because you're going to love this
because you read all the fantasy novels
you got to watch game of thrones i don't
remember game of thrones i don't
remember the first episode you remember
all the sex and gay stuff i sure didn't
really
i mean i i should have she's 12. gay
stuff she's 12.
we watched it and well the season her
brother
yeah and not only that peter on top of
their dead son
there's that come on daddy and peter
kids watching english
in a whorehouse he's a small person he's
in a [ __ ] he's getting blown yes
and my favorite part that scene comes in
and i go i'm literally like
no like that and my daughter to her
credit just went i got to go and just
got the [ __ ] out
and i game of thrones and then her mom
found out that i had shown her game of
thrones and i got
my ex was like are you out of your
[ __ ] mind and i was like
this is what i was doing it was like
this sorry but if you but if you could
just get rid of the sex scenes it's a
great
it's like especially she's into that
yeah but
incest and a small guy getting blown not
yet
there's a lot of murder too a lot of
murder all the murder
a lot of titties a lot of titties back
then looked [ __ ]
lit dude it did lit it did look lit yeah
don't say lit you're too old for it
i like being lit though dude the game of
thrones i'm watching right now
second time it's it's better the second
time you know all the storyboard and yep
it's great
yep yeah it was very interesting i
uh yeah you missed you didn't you were
supposed to come to the show and said
you missed chrissy d
griffin opened on friday big j shop
stevie was there stevie got up i wish i
really steve stevie and cat bought a dog
they bought a wiener dog
you did uh yeah we're picking it up in
september you're what we're picking it
up in september
uh that's when it's eight weeks old and
it can go oh he's young
yeah it was just born i think last week
and so you so you order them online then
you gotta drive
steve was saying you know drive to
austin flight off yeah because the
leader
is in franklin texas and so we have to
go to austin and then drive too hurt is
there not enough dogs in la why the [ __ ]
you going through all this uh
stevia really likes blonde wiener dogs
basically like a dog that looks like him
weird he also likes corgis yes and so
it's really rare to find a blonde wiener
dog and we could only find one
from a breeder in texas do you have to
have a blonde wiener doug white why not
he's obsessed with the blonde wiener
dogs it has to be blonde it is cute like
that dog
yeah tell me that doesn't look like
stevie well that's not a wiener dog is
it yeah that's weiner dog
that's right that's a doc so that one's
cool you see that one down there with
like the long here
that thing looks like [ __ ] well you guys
i like their noses though
i mean it's cute i just want a dog
that's going to bite a home invader but
that's my own problem that's not going
to your corgis hey bubba you're cory's
not going to do that german shepherd
will though yes he will yeah
that corgi's not doing to do [ __ ] that's
correct oh we changed the name
i'm not naming it uni anymore i'm naming
it butters like the character from south
park oh that'd be cool butterscotch yeah
and it's blonde butter's a great name oh
that's dope and it's a blonde dog
butters is cool
is it a girl or boy boy that's great
butter's a great name butter's a great
name
we just want to be able to dog's a big
step in a relationship is it
oh yeah the biggest step beside the kid
you guys are sharing a [ __ ] live
creature
i mean we live together already i feel
like that's bigger than having a dog way
bigger because you guys break it up
now it's complicated who gets the dog oh
he and i have had this fight before i
say i'm keeping the dog he says he's
going to steal the dog if we were who
paid for the dog
uh he and i both did that's tricky well
but it's technic
i don't know yeah i just feel like dog
goes to wherever wherever it the dog is
going to be happiest
if you have left enough room but the
thing is
that this is this is a harbinger for
kids because what happens is all of a
sudden
whoops yeah i mean the dog's a huge step
cat
but also i feel like it's more stevie's
dog because he's the one balls deep in
gold wiener dogs
like you would have got a dog in la if
it wasn't for stevie
yeah true well i hadn't lived in an
actual house before
like me living with stevie he and i only
lived in apartments for a while so
he hasn't had a dog either yeah but it's
but it's his vision to get
his kids are so i feel like he
definitely needs it more than i would
like it'd be depressing so that doesn't
hang out stevie more than you because
stevie does
nothing monday through saturday like
he's gonna be at home
he hangs he hates him with the doll no
one can hang better than stevie
true he's just low i mean that talks to
me with him
24 7. basically it's me stevie's dog
yeah that dog again
yeah my friend two dogs that are uh
giant mastiffs and love mastiffs yeah
the problem is that you can't have two
mastiffs like that unless you know
because just so much dog and when
they're puppies it's just a lot i mean
they're [ __ ] i slobber so much my
friend asked myself they take dinosaur
shits too that's a problem
i take like it's like me [ __ ] on the
ground they shoot in your house the
nightmare yeah
that my friend went to uh brought his
kids to the zoo in l.a i didn't know it
was a great zoo
delay zoo i never been i didn't even
know there was you've been here the one
next to glendale right
i know uh kind of glendale-ish yeah i
get that it's off to 101. apparently
there's
every animal there chimps everything
it's a zoo though you know i i i didn't
know i thought it was like there's la in
san diego
oh they're the biggest zoos oh bro
you've been alley too long you know we
had a [ __ ] zoo we're the biggest city
in the nation i didn't know that i'm an
idiot
i've been here only 26 years but here's
the thing they got a croc too
all zoos dude dude i don't know dude
you're annoying me not knowing zeus have
animals
huh i said to my friends i said to my
friend's kid i go if you could have one
animal as a pet he just got back from
the zoo apparently knows everything
about animals
if you could have one pet what would it
be he looks at me like it like this like
he goes like this
he goes and either like dumb question i
go what
he goes anteater i go why he goes
because they're majestic
oh that's cool and i go what does that
mean he goes they run really fast they
can climb
and they eat ants if i have hands i just
let him free great idea
it's like all right i can't argue with
you i can't believe you've ever been to
l.a
it's an american alligator when you have
a nile crocodile
talk to me i took i took tiger to the la
zoo years ago
and as soon as we walked in there was a
rhino [ __ ] another right now no
dude it's dick was the size of this sign
it was
huge it was the best part of the trip
yeah they got giant tongs and then
there's like a whole class and the
teacher's like let's keep moving
you know they don't apparently act like
it doesn't happen that's like all right
everybody keep moving rhinos are busy
i'm like no they're not
that's how you're taking it i watched a
monkey a chimp or whatever let's [ __ ]
jack off and then start eating its own
oof yeah that was interesting and same
thing
all right let's uh yes okay okay
let's get going let's move it down
before it picks the [ __ ] the san diego
zoo has that
dope uh panda exhibit it's like
super cool panda exhibit they're all
about pandas
and they just and because the pandas are
so like rare to see like they have some
baby panda i guess
you get a it's a time limit like each
person gets two minutes and you gotta
keep moving
wow that's dope really in person can you
see do they have chimps at the
la zoo yeah dude it's a zoo you got
chimps
name a [ __ ] ships are hard to [ __ ]
deal with i'm just asking hey
every zoo in america has a champ yeah
every single one they got chimpanzee
bonzi is there whoa yeah there's
but my friend told me that there was the
male chimp the the dominant
the higher the patriarch or whatever
who's just a [ __ ]
jacked out at this zoo yeah like a real
badass every zoo you've ever been to has
chimps it's the first thing they buy
i don't know not the san diego they have
bonobos no
san diego has chimps dude shims no shims
bonobos are
miniature chimps but they solve things
with sex chimpanzees solve things with
violence so the problem is when you have
a bunch of
chimps there it's there's a chance one
of them gets killed not these gems not
the zoo
no no they're boring as [ __ ] until
they're not
zoos are kind of lame the animals are
all depressed in there i don't like them
they're all bored i don't like them
no i just don't my kid doesn't like me
though after 30 minutes tiger's like
dude where are we going we just don't i
don't
san diego zoo is as good as it gets but
they say that la's just as good i gotta
be honest la's right up there is it
right i can't believe you've never been
the laser i never it's [ __ ]
massive it should bring the kids if they
like it will my
nine year old and 13 year old like space
jam are they too old
uh are you kids not really into sports
though right no
no then why not yeah she's watching game
of thrones and [ __ ] right now
yeah she's an anime i don't think so
yeah she's yeah
she's it's good though you know it's
good if your kids into sports
it's a good [ __ ] movie have you seen
i heard this new movie pig with nicholas
cage is supposed to be really [ __ ]
good
really what's it on he's lost his
truffle pig oh i'm out
i hear it's really good i told you this
some people who know the difference
people interested
let's look at what's what's on rotten
tomatoes oh he looks terrible
yeah but i hear he's phenomenal he's a
great actor dude yeah he's just crazy
he's crazy
he's legit crazy he's about a t-rex head
like dude you have no money oh he buys
he buys castles and [ __ ] yeah he's great
yeah he's uh he's
absolutely reckless he's reckless but
he's a killer
rotten tomatoes how to do 97
yeah that's super hot yeah it's supposed
to be really good
it's supposed to be like insane
dude 97 is great an audience 84.
well nicholas cage i mean he's made some
weird movies but
he's also awesome he's great dude yeah
he's awesome he gets made like every
other [ __ ] thursday he sure does
she's just a i watch pigs my friend knew
him a little bit and
and and uh he had a uh he just bought an
emerald tree boa
he's great you know he just has money
and just just having
he wears ridiculous clothes he has the
weird [ __ ] ear plugs and [ __ ]
yeah legend though dude yeah and he
wanted he would always want to share
things with you
like he'd have this special caviar he'd
pull out of a vault and put it on this
he sounds great
try this he sounds fantastic watch you
and watch your face
i like this guy well he's a guy who came
up in la
with all sean penn and all those guys
super famous
did all of that and just said [ __ ] l.a
[ __ ]
after a while you're like well he lives
here but i hear you face off
yeah and i get [ __ ] yeah especially
right now the mass mandate isn't it
weird they put it back on it's
unbelievable to me
and everybody's like okay the la sheep
are like we'll do it
yeah i thought there would be more of an
uproar
you know it's amazing to me nothing it's
a
it's it depends on what you listen to
we have a friend let me say anything we
have a friend who wants to bet me a
hundred grand that we get locked down in
november again
and he's like look at the recall they're
doing the recall they moved up september
because they'll lock you down in
november
like [ __ ] but they'd the only way they'd
lock you down in november is if they
could justify the number of deaths and
the over see
it's all about overwhelming the health
care system yeah yeah
so but you got to figure in in the
winter the cold's going to come back
they like to contribute that to cove but
no matter what right
so yeah could get dicey that
yeah that i don't know do we lock down
again i i just i can't
i can't no i can't i cannot that'd be
that'd be the straw in the camera
sometimes it's worth getting arrested
for
passive resistance i mean i guess dude
what are you fighting what are you gonna
do you're making a statement and you get
a group of people that come into places
public areas without masks and you sit
down
i mean good luck with that bubba it
works no it doesn't it does no it
doesn't pass the resistance works
they've tried to all last lockdown
restaurants enough people do it you do
it
you have a bunch of people who did it in
a target here in california do you
remember
they were like yelling at people in the
target for wearing masks and trying to
rip them off mm-hmm
some of that's a little the government's
not going to bend to that
you you'd have to be like mass amount of
people
what has to happen is they have what
when you make enough of a spectacle
they have to justify because what
happens then is the
the politicians and health bureaucrats
put on the spot to justify
why these lockdowns are happening with
so much civil unrest
and then then what happens is you don't
have enough civil unrest well that's how
you put pressure on people on your
elected officials if you have civil
unrest
we don't have civil rights that's the
number one ingredient we need and we
don't have that
everyone's cool with it that's right if
you've been not cool with it then knew
something's like oh [ __ ] i don't need
this that's just
a recall i don't need this i agree but
also the the
what for people not in california you
gotta understand the state of california
is saying the mandate
doesn't make any sense it's not backed
by science it's just the county of los
angeles
that's what's nuts it's incredible and
then the it's almost like they want the
power they yeah it's the power
sadistic and then the lapd was like
we're not enforcing this
like again this isn't backed by science
we're not enforcing any of these rules
so technically you don't have to but l.a
county sheriff won't enforce new mass
media not backed by science
so it's really up to the stores and
restaurants what they want to do
yeah yeah i don't know the most i'm
going to i mean i went to starbucks and
i totally forgot
like i'm not a guy who's going to fight
this i mean what are you going to do
and i just forgot no one said anything i
walked down like why the [ __ ] is
everybody back in mass and i was like oh
my god
the masked man did i went to costco
without a mask when everybody was in
math
yesterday i'm lying
yeah you're lying i'm doing a little bit
of a lie yeah i just realized i i uh
you're gonna wear them i did go in there
and then everybody's wearing a mask and
then i
put one on but i kept my nose out tight
move yeah that was my way of resisting
yeah there's not much we can do no there
but the i went to costco the day before
and everybody had mass and now i didn't
have i was like me and three other
people it doesn't matter i was like are
you kidding me right now i went to the
mall on saturday nobody had mascot
nobody nobody nothing good
yeah but the the mandate i find them so
claustrophobic
and and like the worst is for kids we
know you know
the effect has on kids and their lungs
and stuff it's terrible
it drives me [ __ ] nuts man yeah i
just wonder if people could just push
back
some because you know how it is
especially in l.a the the
with new some give them a niche and take
a [ __ ] month
if they go oh [ __ ] they don't care about
the mass all right let's lock down the
businesses
look that's the history of that's the
history
of our world where where the way you
control people
is it's a gradual you gradually take
there may figure it out look at the
lockdowns remember like it's only
two weeks yeah a year later y'all figure
out what they're going to do
the best thing i heard was the the idea
is well
this could never be this the united
states could never turn into hitler's
germany or stalin's russia oh yes well
they said the same thing
well no yesterday they also said the
same thing i realized i realized it
could once i realized how
everyone's just go like sheep i'm like
[ __ ] dude
well we we are a country that was based
on the idea that you know the government
is
the government has to be afraid of its
electorate the government has to be
served at our whim yeah that's not what
it is it's a refined democracy you do it
through
you know the legislature represent the
people yeah not anymore but it's
unbelievable yeah
that's what bothers me so i don't know
yeah the biggest challenge is facing all
of us the biggest challenge
is disinformation both sides
are using disinformation misinformation
mal information whatever you want to
call it [ __ ]
and their narrative to alienate or
isolate the other side
so what happens with that is that we
have to have a we have to have
a group of people a non-partisan group
that can at least we can rely on to say
this is true or this is not true
that's very important like you can win
elections that way you can you can
you can literally float rumors that by
the time people find out
it's [ __ ] it's too late so we have
to figure
out a way to do that that's very
important that's the new challenge if
you read
what most people futurists and people
are talking about this stuff they're all
like the best
look at the mass mandate now like if you
if if newsom or garcetti whoever locked
us down
with the mass bandit if you would have
had like a town hall meeting
and someone stood up like hey all right
we're down for the mass but why are you
doing it
what science do you have and if you laid
out the stats i think most people like
all right that makes sense
but when the the science doesn't back it
we have the lowest covert per capita out
of any place in the nation
then it's just like why why are you see
that's what that's all i'm asking for i
want to why
can you tell me why i want a health
bureaucracy
you don't deserve it here are the stats
that's my issue newsroom goes you don't
deserve it it's unbelievable
i need stats but then how it can't last
too long because think about this
they've sold out the dodger stadium the
ram stadium they're sold out dude
they're sold out so you're gonna
say well then also so they're sold out
so
if we play in la you're gonna have half
capacity but then full capacity in
arizona
texas so that makes no sense but then
also if we're forced to wear a mask
why would anybody get vaccinated well so
if your entire push is to scare people
and get vaccinated
if we still have to wear a mask why
would you get vaccinated they're the
hardest
because because the thing to get
vaccinated was oh we can have freedom if
we have vaccine we get freedom
the problem we're all vaccinating here
but now we're back in mass
so if you're not vaccinating you're like
no do i have to wear a mask why would i
do it there's a large but there's a
large anti-vax movement and also
americans are not going to stand for the
fact that you have to prove you've been
vaccinated right it's a violation of
their privacy
so it's it's it's difficult because what
you're saying is
are you vaccinated and people say yeah i
am you don't know if it's true
now if you get on a plane or you go to
other countries like france you have to
show that you've been vaccinated
you've been double vaccinated that same
thing with most of europe the amer
americans don't stand for that they're
just like
nah you're not going to make me carry a
vaccine passport try floating that out
and see how far you get
you could float in la guaranteed
passengers in l.a
it's such a shame yeah in l.a and so it
becomes a difficult thing if
you know i do think vaccines work and i
do think we have two billion
and counting people to prove that the
death rate has
fallen drastically because of vaccines
but there are people that first of all
people don't trust the science with that
they don't know what the side effects
are they're worried about it
so the the scientific community hasn't
done a good enough job explaining
well look at my show got johnson johnson
pulled his dick out you won't be like
that
maybe maybe it's from the vaccine dude
that's what i think i mean you're
spreading the rumor i'm just saying the
guy did pull his dog out that's what he
said he had a little patch
you saw a little you saw a little needle
a little needle hole
in his arm he says the vaccination is
why he pulls his dick out well my
my nephew got the vaccine and he's like
my knee my knees been killing me so
something
he was limping for like i don't know
that's from the vaccination bubba
i love it though it might have been but
i mean some you know you can get a
little
you get a little like psychosomatically
you can be like for sure [ __ ] can happen
and you're like i [ __ ]
i pulled my dick out and during the show
if if they kept the mass mandate for
another year i just moved to ventura i
just move up the road to thousands
yeah i'm not going to leave you you can
carry a gun up there you can do
everything have them
they never lock down yeah my buddy
you know him he moved to venture and he
goes um
he goes i can carry a gun and i'll tell
you this because
i got a group of guys we meet with every
week and we're forming a militia oh
that's smart
that's good i was like oh that's
productive all right
yeah that sounds good you guys planning
on you're working out like
you know routes and vantage points i
think chappelle just has a head cold
because hopefully he's back
by wednesday or friday hopefully yeah
chappelle's not feeling well so
that's why he's not here in case you're
wondering i don't think he has the delta
he just has a head cold
there's a lot of that going around or he
passed away we don't know yet we're
trying to figure it out i haven't heard
from today
yeah so there's a chance you could god
forbid
right hopefully not hopefully not all
right jim what do you got let's take a
little break from chatting with the kid
brian callan because guess what man
you ever feel drained after a workout
you're like man i'm tired
well not anymore kids i got some for you
that's where true nigerian comes in true
nigerian fuels the body's
energy engines maintains cellular
metabolism and even supports heart
health
all great things i have more energy than
ever
11 published human clinical studies
backed by noble
prize winners true nigerian a supplement
that's clinically proven
to boost nad levels all right an
essential coenzyme required for cellular
energy and repair
since taking true nitrogen it helps the
muscles recover after your workout
you just have more zast in life man all
right
and right now you guys new customers can
save 10 off your first purchase
by going to truenigen.com fighter and
use the code fighter that's true
niagen.com
fighter t-r-u-n-i-a-g-e-n.com
fighter code fighter to save 10 off your
first purchase
truenigen.com fighter code fighter these
statements have not
been evaluated by the food and drug
administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat or cure or
prevent any diseases
again truenigen.com fighter code fighter
alrighty okay so
idris elba recently got onto instagram
and he said that he wants everyone on
the platform to be verified he's 60
though yeah he's 60.
okay he wants everyone to be verified
because he thinks it's weird that you
can go on social media
talk a bunch of [ __ ] or like talk to
people and they don't know who you are
and so he oh i see he says it's similar
so there's no like troll accounts no
troll accounts and i also think it's
just like so you know
who you're talking to like this is an
actual person not like you're lying
from a burner account the process of
varication requires them to prove their
identity so everyone knows who is
speaking
social media companies should make this
mandatory i get what he's saying
currently social media is boarding and
playing not having to show id
that would never happen well if cowards
are being supported by a
vial of privacy and secrecy then social
media is not a safe place
so he just wants it to be more like it'd
make it a nicer place maybe or something
if i don't like any kind of right now
that's when
i'm not your username so he wants people
to go by like official name
yeah or you could just leave the delta
the delta
what's happening uh smoking too much
that well also there you go kids
yeah yeah i don't know i get what idris
is saying i always say well he's also
from the uk
they don't have freedom of speech over
there right well they do but
in the uk yeah they have freedom of
speech do they the uk
i heard that there's like a specific
like like if you say certain
you can't say certain things like there
was that uh tom daley situation where
someone said that uh
his dad would be disappointed he didn't
like win gold or some [ __ ] and he was
arrested
it was like a random two different
speech show you have free speech in in
the uk yeah
canada has um like a hate speech law
there we go that's why i'm thinking like
that that's what jordan peterson made
got famous for for fighting against and
and they passed it uh in in some ways
it's compelled speech
um and i'm not sure i think that's been
challenged
is on the right path though he's saying
like these trolls hide behind these
weird
pseudo names and can just spew out vile
[ __ ]
but if it was under their real legal
name you could find out who they are
then i doubt they're going to be hiding
behind this like fake avatar account
i'm down with that i'm down with it
because i think tinder has something
like that where you
have your account verified if you put in
your id to show like oh this is actually
who they say they are and then they're
attempting that just you were verified
yeah but then again is that a violation
of your privacy just to speak your mind
and and to have your own account that's
the other question yeah but is it but
is it okay to hide behind whatever
booger one two three underscore and just
say racial
no because would you say that same race
as [ __ ] if it was your actual account
absolutely not but that's only one case
the the real debate is
should you know should you be forced to
disclose your identity when you just
want to interact on social media and
and maybe you just want to remain
anonymous which is your right as a human
being too yeah but that's the exception
isn't it i think
i think so much i disagree i think what
he's saying is like
these people spewing this [ __ ] wouldn't
do it if it was if they have to
i understand consequences i understand
what if i said to you you're not allowed
to be anonymous
you'd be like wait a minute you know i
wouldn't i'd be like yeah cool because
i'm not anonymous
well and i would never get behind
something and say some [ __ ] i went
so you want to give a central power the
ability to say you have to say who you
are yeah i i have a problem with it i
don't have a problem i think it's fine
to be announced i think
i'd clean i think it would clean up the
hate on social media
um okay so then how do you feel about
hate speech would you outlaw it yes
you shouldn't be on the platform outlaw
hate speech yes
shouldn't be on the platforms okay but
what about if you so so you you would
not allow
people to to say something racist
in general not on not if i own twitter
facebook or youtube no okay they're
they're
they are allowed you are allowed now on
twitter and facebook as long as it's not
directed
to at someone specifically right because
that falls under your first amendment
right sure i happen to believe in the
first amendment
which is you're allowed to say anything
you want um
the the one thing there are there are
exceptions like screaming fire in a
thing or
advocating violence directly towards
somebody saying go kill that guy that
would be
that would be you'd be in trouble for
that sure but overall you know
protecting free speech is very important
in general right
and i think to a certain extent and i
well to every extent to me but but i
mean
yes i don't think so there are i think
when kids are committed suicide getting
bullied on social media there has to be
some recourse
over action we can't just say well it's
freedom of speech it's okay that this
well there are harassment laws
there are harassment laws right so there
are but you have to be very careful
about you know i think when you say
well you're not allowed to be anonymous
so i can't write a book that's anonymous
i can't say something that's anonymous
because sometimes you want to just
express yourself
under a pseudonym sometimes you have a
pen name which authors have done so
it's a slippery slope is what i'm trying
to say and and it's a debate that i
think has been had
and thought about pretty pretty pretty
thoroughly
i don't think so on social media no on
social media
category from having a uh well that was
for
so that's the other they said you're
spreading misinformation well there you
go so so
we just didn't want to win the election
we don't want him to be able to contact
his followers well but i understand so
so facebook
let's just take facebook let's take
twitter let's take
um uh uh instagram youtube instagram
no let's take youtube let's take youtube
let's take facebook let's say
um twitter um you if
if you have a group of people spreading
like they've they've got a sophisticated
information network and they start
saying something like
this particular group of people let's
say koreans
or chinese people in this particular
neighborhood are responsible for
x y and z and it's a lie and we've seen
this in other countries
and then you get a mob of people that
with their pitchforks come into that
neighborhood and start causing
recon damage sure or let's just talk
about what's going on now
say what you will about vaccines but
vaccines
do have an effect they have had a
positive effect on
i'm going to get [ __ ] for this but on on
the fact that covet is no longer as much
a threat
and old people take it they they can
move about and they won't die
because they're immune to covet that if
you look at the
two billion plus people who've had it
and you look at the actual
data the real data from all over the
world that bears
that bears out that is a fact when you
have people who are
actively spreading misinformation about
a vaccine like for example it makes
women infertile
which is not true there's just no
science to that but there are strong
networks that are saying that and people
are buying into it so people aren't
getting the vaccine
as a platform you kind of have a duty to
tackle that you have a duty to kind of
go i might get sued
this is misinformation and it's actually
causing the economy to stay closed
this is not freedom of speech back to
your point that would be
this is my this is the biggest challenge
we face
misinformation and deliberate
misinformation lying
uh on a platform when you own it
privately you might be responsible for
that so you kind of have to limit
free speech in that sense that's what
i'm saying but but then you open up the
floodgates because then
it's a big [ __ ] problem i don't have
the answer i
i am a big advocate of free speech in
the first amendment 100
and the way to deal with free speech is
more free speech but we are
we are dealing with a precedent we've
never had to deal with it before right
that's what i'm saying
yeah i don't think it's been looked at
or studied that much well it's new i
mean i'm saying you're into your point
that's your point that's my original
point to your point so what do you do
because you get so much [ __ ] when you
censor people i don't think you allow
hate speech or misinformation
that's their responsibility how do you
define hate speech
here's the problem now because
somebody's defining that
so the problem with define hate speech
is if i say a man is a man and a woman
is a woman
or if i say biological women biological
men
shouldn't be in women's sports let me
tell you something
that's considered hate speech on a lot
of platforms why
because a very active minority tiny
group of people that are very active and
loud
are bullying and making it very
dangerous for you to say otherwise
because you will lose your job
now we've got a problem you understand
slippery slope it is that's
that's and and we know that historically
it's a slippery slope because somebody
has to delineate and designate and
define
what what hate speech is and that's why
every time it hits the supreme court
it's shot down because
because you're like who's the one who's
who the [ __ ] is saying this is hate
speech because you can start saying
anything
and this this agenda with this trans
trans agenda thing
there are people in that group who are
who are just not reasonable about
certain things
do you think biological men should be
allowed to compete in women's fighting
for example
i i i mean you know or or do you think
i'm do you think
a man who had no estrogen replacement
let's just take an extreme example
and they have long hair or whatever and
they say i want to i want to sprint
in the women's division of the olympics
i think i think they need to
they need to open up more divisions for
more transgender there you go that's
fine
now hold on they they should be allowed
to completely get sanctioned for saying
that sometimes in certain platforms
you really could you'd be in some
trouble for saying that
you'd get blow back and you and if you
worked for certain organizations
they would tell you you have to you have
to apologize for what you just said for
sure right
and that's that's where i that's why
protecting freedom of speech is so
[ __ ] important
it's just a slippery slope man it's
[ __ ] see we get into this and all of
a sudden you're like you realize how
thick it is he's just like
i don't envy i don't envy youtube and
twitter
i don't envy that having to deal with
that [ __ ] that what else you got jen
so a woman was recently arrested
because she broke into a dentist's
office and stole
23 000 worth of cash and
checks she then when she was arrested
told the police officers that she
actually was there a few days prior
and she actually stole um the
anise anesthetic is that anesthesia yeah
the anesthesia
that the dental office had tossed out
she went in pretended like she was a
dentist put someone under and then
pulled 13 teeth
out of their mouth while they were out
how did you do that i think they were
nobody found
nobody yeah oh yeah uh the patient was
unconscious when she started taking out
the teeth
but how did the dentist not be like
that's my question
they don't specify how she got it i had
a mask yeah also
also i i'm sorry how do you extract 13
teeth
first of all why don't this guy's got
too many teeth
and i've always wanted to pull that's
hard she's crazy i would imagine it's
kind of hard to pull a [ __ ] tooth
isn't it
unless that's a fantasy of yours but
yeah she did that and then a few days
later she came back to rob the place
so she got away with the original going
just for like a cavity
film it did not specify 13 teeth or
something
well i assume they're just gonna hook
this person with some dope veneers on
the house though
it might have worked out i don't know
man it's like we got good news and bad
news bad good news is you have no more
cavities
bad news is you're missing 13 [ __ ] tc
you can't smile for a while he's a
[ __ ] son oh my god
she looks like a [ __ ] real woman
13 teeth you just did that huh you just
saw
a mouth that was open and said i gotta
pull those teeth clearly [ __ ] crazy
yeah she decided the teeth had to come
out why does the dental shop look like a
pizza hut
it i don't know why the landscaping
looks like
[ __ ] you know it's in the desert
somewhere yeah yeah you said no water
to uh nevada yeah that looks like that's
meth cat
meth central now let me ask you a
question when was the last time you were
at the dentist you good about the
dentist you go to
you go i went eight years ago and they
go man you
you're really gifted in the in the teeth
department
because the enamel on your teeth for the
reason like your teeth are great i went
say no more never went back me too
because it prior to that i didn't go for
like 10 years
and then i went my girl forced me to go
so i went like man
you're genetically your teeth are pretty
great like you don't need to come as
much as other people went
oh you know you [ __ ] up i will never
be back
unless my teeth start to hurt and the
only time i'm going back is my tooth
crumbles yeah that's
it i'm not going the dentist you got to
go to get a cleaning every six months
my girl goes every six months my kids do
i never go i don't have time yep my kids
are there every six months i just never
i'm afraid
i'm not afraid i just don't want to go
they said i have amazing gums she
couldn't believe how good my gums do
when she told me about she's like your
teeth right or reason
they're crazy like you have no issues
i'm like really they're not brown to you
yeah like they're brown but
what you couldn't believe that no
they're definitely brown because you
drink so much coffee but
outside that they're [ __ ] perfect
they couldn't believe that i never get a
teeth cleaning even though my teeth are
pretty yellow same thing she was like
you know for a guy who hasn't had his
teeth cleaned in five years your teeth
are but i use that sonicare toothbrush
so apparently that's really good
i do too but i mean i see your teeth
dude you could do some helpful come on
man yeah come on
when she told him like god you [ __ ] up
telling me this right now if you just
were like man you need to get
back in here the dentist i'll find any
reason
to go to the dentist the [ __ ] worst
the dentist
13 [ __ ] teeth though that's so many
teeth imagine waking up missing 13 [ __ ]
no teeth i just feel like you know
so this weight lifter from uganda went
to tokyo to see if he qualified for the
olympics
and he just didn't qualify to go
to the main games and actually perform
so before he was going to be
flown back to uganda he actually escaped
his hotel room and left a note saying
that he's going to start his life over
in japan and now living in uganda was
too hard
he told his teammates a few days before
hey
i'm going to leave i don't but once you
guys find out please tell my wife
and my kids that like oh uh i'm starting
my life oh
[ __ ] yeah oh wow and so they're trying
to look for him right now
that sounds first of all like first of
all not to be weird but
it's not hard to find that guy yeah
there are exactly three
oh the giant black guy from uganda
strolling around japan
yeah you're not it's not my theory he
met a japanese gal
you think yep and she was like whoa he
looks like he looks like he's crying
there
he looks nice a muscular um unless they
get out
super athlete from uganda he's probably
working with
you know more than the he just leaves
his wife and kid like yeah you figure
out
i moved to japan yeah yeah that and he
told his teammates to tell his wife and
kids
also japan japan isn't going to
necessarily be like okay
i would imagine japan's yeah yeah how
are you going to work immigrating to
japan is super hard
from what i've heard one of the toughest
yeah i think they allowed six
syrians in like during the crisis when
it was taking syrians in
they left they allowed six people are
speculating that he bought
a train ticket to three hours
out of tokyo to try to get somewhere
else like he's not staying in tokyo
he's gonna try to go to another country
since it's gonna be
probably pretty hard for him to blend in
yeah and his story doesn't end well
they're gonna ship them back to uganda's
families i'm like what the [ __ ] dude
he's gonna live up the street from his
kids yeah that's not good
i mean he probably liked it and this is
just a clip from bar stool
look what happens to this woman
this is monday hitting you like oh [ __ ]
that's
that's not good yeah ran over by a [ __ ]
and a scooter yeah
that's a tough one that hurt that
it just looks like it hurts so bad at
least the lady ran over
skinny uh i just felt that on my feet
and my lower legs
you thought you were having a bad
morning christian yeah you're that poor
lady yeah
she just got because she got a car wreck
this morning yup
i got it yeah it was not great
and was it was all traffic stopped and
someone waved you in like you go that's
what happened to me when i was i was 16
when i have that one ass was like oh
yeah you could maybe
maybe he saw the car coming off no he
didn't see it they just they look they
don't see anything like yeah you're good
and then you go
for whatever reason you don't know that
[ __ ] person like thanks dude and then
you go in to make a left
and the car goes did your airbags deploy
no thank god not no
but the lineman the the actual
structural damage is all [ __ ] up
hit the she hit the front right fender
my car
like right between the door
and the wheel so that she mainly clipped
the wheel
the wheel was bent inwards and the door
was all [ __ ] up so you couldn't like
open the passenger
all the way yeah yeah yep so
not looking forward to that it's a great
way to start off my week yeah i'd rather
be this lady trucked by the fat girl on
the scooter yeah i would too
you have a picture of it by chance uh it
yeah it doesn't look that bad though
when the picture's
pulling up cool it's not gonna look air
dropping we're just sketching
i saw this um this is on clips
this has got to be the blackest korean
i've ever seen this is incredible
make sure the volume is good
that cake looks nice gotta be the
blackest corian i ever seen
you've been going in that was too hard
i've been cutting since i've been here
[Music]
i know you ain't in the bathroom are you
two hours
two hours [ __ ] look he's recording
he called me i've been calling you i
don't know what you went
[ __ ] that's what probably fishy
you think you want fishing i think
something you know the number to the
fish creek
college creek that's crazy so what about
the [ __ ] ass here here
you call the fish creek that's a [ __ ] uh
i feel like she's uh she's awesome yeah
she is awesome
all right well she's been in the hood
for a long time yeah she's there's a
bunch of koreans in atlanta
so just look at the caption here
if you expect me to watch soccer's got
to be like this they just did some sort
of like
an app to make him do that little
squiggly thing
it's just god damn a little thing like
that make it that much more fun funny
man
all right we're talking about the
masquerading and then we were just
talking about knott's berry farm
oh did you go yet jin no not yet but a
lot of people will start
sending me like tips very few how to
sneak in alcohol and
stuff um so someone actually climbed to
the top of this ride
up there's not food's going wild
well that's tempting supreme screamer
that's tempting get down
bro look at this he's like this yeah
that now what you worry about is that
they're gonna jump
that's what you worry about that's what
i thought so too
bro look how high that is dude yeah you
don't want to see that person jump
that's what you know about you like
[ __ ] they're gonna jump look at how hard
that thing is that's where i climb
up and i talk them down that's the most
exciting thing that's ever happened in
knoxville
yeah i climb up and i go hey brother
come on come on down let's talk
and he gets on my back and i bring him
down right
um that's not a good one this one was so
this was like last week but
there's some sort of research done and
said there's no evidence
to support that marijuana helps of
course athletes but that's not what this
story is about i don't know
the story is about her breaking the
rules and she already knew consequences
that's all that end of story yeah like
yeah she should be allowed to race but
those
them dim the rules there's the rules
condemns the rules isn't the ufc
allowing weed now
did i hear that mm-hmm just you can't
punish the yeah they won't punish you
for it
this is uh actually not the ufc but an
sac
the the nevada state athletic commission
good for them
uh i saw this look crazy too so it's a
a goose order feeding goldfish
because she's [ __ ] crazy she's
[ __ ] yeah she's probably oh she
no she grabs food and watch she's
feeding the goldfish
uh i think they're taking the food from
the
so goose also probably funny because
she's [ __ ] in the water with this
[ __ ]
so it's kind of disgusting how come
people don't eat geese more
yeah they're thick yeah a lot of meat i
thought the same thing
like by the balboa lake there's their
[ __ ] dinosaur yeah somebody kill this
thing and
rotisserie this [ __ ] sounds delicious
i know you guys want to eat are all big
wear like size 12 shoes i know [ __ ]
eat the feet man
i agree just trying to get it kill those
things spice them
juicy you see a turkey turkeys are
[ __ ] hideous yeah [ __ ] kill those
handsome geese over there man what a
goose yeah so you know but they do make
the geese do make your um i guess your
pond look good but
canadian geese i'd love to eat i'm
telling you man we gotta go [ __ ]
choke out some of these balboa lake
geese they're [ __ ] huge yeah if i'm a
bomb i'm killing that [ __ ] thing
that's right
that's gonna have your hands full though
dude the things
there's dude you've i'm telling you dude
we will go to lake balboa
you've never seen a bigger [ __ ] goose
in your life is that right
it's jacked jacked i don't know what it
is
i'll chat it's a black [ __ ] goose
yeah it's a canadian jacket
it's black yeah these ones black white
might be a black swan
one's black ones don't [ __ ] around
either you know i'm talking ten times
the size of that
at least ten times so what about what is
it sweet that was this one that was a
black swan we just saw
yeah i don't wanna eat that [ __ ] no i'm
talking about look
type in giant goose this thing is a
[ __ ] pterodactyl
and we gotta kill it do people normally
eat geese [ __ ] no
i don't i haven't i mean they eat the
goose's liver
foie gras right where they stuff the but
i haven't seen
that they're like that but i don't know
how big that one is but
it looks like that that's a giant
[ __ ] goose
i'm telling you lake balboa giant i told
tiger i'm like dude don't get too
[ __ ] close to that thing you have
your hands
right there and they're aggressive man
that's a do lap geese huh
all right these things look stupid
compared to the best they swim they'll
they'll
fly all the way to the arctic and hang
out in that cold and be like i'm fine
yeah that's it that's that's yeah
they're aggressive man all right that's
it apparently
that's a grown man yeah that's a good
thrown golfer golfer yeah dude take your
club out and [ __ ] club that's [ __ ]
hilarious
that's him running away from it is he
asian that's
that's great i think so look at that
[ __ ] thing coming at him i'll punch
that thing right here kind of
feel like take one of your clubs out and
[ __ ] tin in the face dude yeah
artistic look how much you know what let
him bite you that is crazy
he's a [ __ ] giant [ __ ] he knows
you [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] bullied by
the look at this [ __ ] idiot trying to
kick him away
like conor mcgregor's upside down what
the [ __ ] are you doing bro that is so
illegal
don't be up kicking a goose you [ __ ]
just stand your ground
look at this i would make sure i'm so
aggressive if my friend was
was this much of a [ __ ] about it i
would make so much fun they are [ __ ]
scary though
i guess if you're a kid you come at me
as a goose i'm going to make it a point
to keep my eyes open and punch you in
the [ __ ] head
you don't wear those khakis and not get
beat up by a goose though all three of
them have
that goose won that goose was like get
out of here get out of my property
look at these guys running i would run
from the goose so i don't hurt it i
don't want to hurt a goose
it depends how aggressive it is yeah my
kids don't beat the chef yeah i'll kick
you in the [ __ ] i'll kick your neck
i'll kick your head off your neck that
guy got [ __ ] i think that's hilarious
i guess i can see running away from it
so i don't hurt it i don't want to
[ __ ] hurt a goose
you got to calm down goose you know what
i do i slap him right in the [ __ ]
side of the head
yeah open hand yep give him a little
stop like that stop
like that right in the [ __ ] and i go
hey stop
what a sketch in i don't know you can
kind of kick them midair oh
our boy show he attani oh the ballers be
for best mlb player
he's a japanese dude he's a pitcher yeah
pitcher leads the league in home runs
too what
yep and pitches giant guy too he hit his
single to first base and
uh beat out the first baseman and get to
the such a stun
really yeah apparently a girl's going
crazy over him too he can't go anywhere
and [ __ ] cat lacks him oh who doesn't
who doesn't really yes i love asian men
i would let that man ruin my life big
ones there you go would you ditch stevie
and his golden [ __ ] wiener dog for
this guy
no i'm too attached to stevie i love you
you haven't met him yet but if i was
single yeah
this is the first dm i shoot from my
account
wow yes yeah me [ __ ] bring up some
more how many wiener
unless you keep the wiener dog too yeah
we can replace that thing
oh honey
all right big shoulders oh yeah he's a
stud he's a big [ __ ] dude
he's he's japanese japanese what's that
he paid the staff at the home run derby
with out of his 150
000 the angel staff yeah
that was like last week that's awesome
he's a good guy he can pitch
and he can [ __ ] hit throw a hundred
mile an hour fastball and leaves the
league at home runs
jesus christ yeah he's a kid
he's killing it their team sucks or
whatever
yeah he's baller i just saw this too i
don't know where this is from but it's
just the
oh wow i don't know what kind of ammo
this is those are gigantic balls those
are brian gallon balls yeah
yep it looks like it hurts it looks like
yeah
can we tie his balls up please look yeah
it's almost like tripping over it
[ __ ] cow what is this thing i don't
know it hurts every time
it looks like some sort of calorie that
looks like a brahma bull that's a brahma
bowl i'm going to say brahma
yeah right well that's a tough goal for
him
that's a tough goal usually instagram
gives you the
option to train we got to be able to
cinch his balls up that poor [ __ ] guy
or just like yeah put a little like uh
tighten the skin
yeah yeah yeah right maybe some like how
about this
take them all take them off
no you don't cut his balls off dude why
not he doesn't need him
he's a [ __ ] brahma bull take his nut
sack off
that's just too much for him to deal
with yeah those are the biggest balls
i've ever seen in my [ __ ] life
look at those i know it sucks they hang
low those hang
low dude those are giant balls
that's nice grass stains on his nuts
yeah
you know what it's kind of sad the
minute a lion finds him or a tiger there
oh my god
first thing they're eating that's the
first thing they grab is your balls take
them right off
a quick sad one bismarck he passed away
i guess he's been
uh battling diabetes for a while he's
only 57 years old oh wow
that's young it's only three years older
than brian callan
that's a bummer that's when you know
you're getting older
young people are threatening because
they're doing [ __ ] you don't understand
and
when friends like people who you grew up
with are dying
of old age
yeah it's kind of crazy and uh i don't
know maybe
meatball do you know about this guy
um uh no now he's not him
he's gay he's gay oh no i said nancy
he's not
gay isn't that isn't that football
player he came out as gay but he's also
republican so
they're all like what the [ __ ] the
raiders guy yeah
that's cool more people coming out of
course there are so this guy came out
yeah but it's cool christian um
i haven't i'm not too familiar with him
he i think he's getting drafted in this
upcoming draft i haven't been following
him that much
but uh nashville is a pretty good team i
think he's
getting drafted in the first round so he
has to be he must be [ __ ] good six
four two seven two
third round third round 217 damn
yeah hockey players are normally they're
in their 200s
okay easy but that's uh i i don't think
any of his teammates
better than i i don't know no not at all
[ __ ] he's a rookie so they don't know
either way hockey's very like open like
that
which i like about it like they don't
honestly give a [ __ ] really can you name
another gay hockey player
um good question i mean who says brandon
you're just patrick
gives me a little gay vibes that was a
long time ago
sean avery gives me gay vibes but to
your point where they're pretty open
oh no i mean look like they're like not
open about being gay book they'll
probably
say uh come out tonight and be like
they're russian hockey
game and there will be there is brian a
lot of russians how do they feel about
gays in russia
they're not that crazy about yes sir i
think you'd rather be gay in other
countries
correct i understand so i'd say i don't
know chris i don't know if they're
like obviously they're gonna have to be
okay with it but the same thing they
were saying like with the nfl players
come out as gay
you're being a black community like they
they're not that most except in the gays
i would say canadians oh too canadians
really don't give a [ __ ] go back to that
statement
because i'm i would say it's not that
he's gay he might get roasted for
this this statement hi everyone well the
past year and a half has been crazy
it's also giving me a chance to find my
true self i'm no longer scared to hide
who i am okay today i'm proud to tell
you when i'm gay
it's been quite the journey to get this
point in my life already dudes are like
hey man
you're making this about the all right
we get it you know but i probably could
not be happier with the decision to come
out
from young age i'm trying to be listen i
i think there's always been gay guys in
the nhl
nfl nba and now they're coming out more
power to you i don't give a [ __ ] but
they've been
like the people think this is something
new these just now they feel safe to
come out yeah
you can do your job i don't give a [ __ ]
if you score goals i don't give a [ __ ]
what you're
sucking at night i agree you know what
i'm saying
are we more tolerant or is it just
because everybody has a camera on their
phone
what do you think what do you mean oh i
don't know
are we more tolerant do you think as a
as a society and as people in general no
i think it's suppressed
right because no one wants to get
canceled right that's what i think too
sometimes i do think that that being gay
now is no big deal and that's been
hard fought for and stuff like that i
still think it's a big i do think people
think that's weird
i think it's less of a deal but i still
think in certain places as countries
it's a tough gig in certain places
country if people didn't have
cameras on their phones and everybody
wasn't being watched you still wouldn't
be
there places you wouldn't be it wouldn't
be that safe to walk around being gay
that's what i'm saying
still a tough life yeah unfortunately
all right this one i didn't get to read
all of it it just popped up but uh
i guess bruce lee wrote a bunch of
different letters way back in the day
to one of his buddies and he would write
him stuff about
delivering certain kind of drugs that he
liked so i don't know he was a drug
addict
uh cocaine i think hell yeah lsd
[ __ ] yeah some other stuff and then so
they're auctioning off the
the letters and they're going up to five
hundred thousand dollars my biggest
question why is writing this these
letters to this dude
that's his homie that delivered the
drugstore he got his drugs from that so
it's always just to see him ordering
drugs
yeah but then there's letters like hey
man things are good in l.a
i i have hippo skeptical hippo eyes
about this but they're they're uh
the letters were verified by the
auctioneer people whatever that is yeah
there are a lot of forgeries that are
verified that's the only thing
and i believe i believe it's a hundred
percent
that yeah i wouldn't wonder if usually
cocaine would he have written that out
back he's ordering to his boy
give me more [ __ ] cocaine didn't have
cell phones back then this one was sold
for 16
000 16 250 and this is how it's
translated
um i wrote coke see coke and coca cola
but they're out reference
pills h oil good taste in paper
that makes sense cash or grass coke
imagination bruce lee did some drugs
that's what they did back then though
or the girls he liked it or there was a
party or whatever it was or he just did
them who cares
yeah i mean back then it was pure bro
it's bruce lee or her i mean movies
doing [ __ ]
jumping kicks and [ __ ] on cocaine it'd
be sick
it's all shredded too yeah
yeah why wouldn't he is that a chin
that's it there there was these guys
doing that i
did the show uh jam in the van and they
give you a lot of
weed and i don't smoke weed but i know
people that do so
it's like talking and i go i'm not a
weed guy i'll do all the cocaine
i'm a little old to do it but i mean i'd
like to do it i won't do it
i have a nose for it but i just you like
i i gotta wake up i
don't want my heart to stop yeah so i go
i go i'd do all the cocaine if i knew it
wasn't lacing fentanyl and i could get
away with it
you know i like uppers and uh the guy
goes
guy looks to me like this and he talks
like this and he goes um
do you like uh you ever do adderall it's
a lot cleaner
i got i did 10 milligrams of material
one time on a plane
and i was how did you take it on a plane
i loved it because
it went i was writing the whole time and
i was able to focus it was unbelievable
and that's 10 milligrams he goes
try 80 sometimes you take it i went oh
you i've done 30. were you an addict
because i couldn't afford to be an i was
definitely 80
jesus christ and i said what'd you do
the whole time and he goes jack off
i was like this conversation guys sounds
like he's
it was a very interesting conversation i
thought i'd share that
how much is 80 how much i mean the big
kills are usually like
30. so 80s they have something like i i
don't know
and i have i've never even heard of 80
milligrams i might
take four pills or whatever yeah they
have vivants which is extended release
and i have prescribed 50 to me i don't
like take them that much because
if i i'll be washing like [ __ ] that's
already clean like i'll be going insane
how many milligrams are there 50. yeah
but that's time released and you cannot
overdose on those
so if ivan's you literally can't for
whatever reason it's a mechanism so
when you say 50 it's giving you 10
milligrams every whatever right that's
cool yeah but that's a lot dude
if i do 10 if i do 10 milligrams of
adderall
i'm [ __ ] that that's that's six hours
of
you know i don't know how people could
do that i don't even do those anymore
i have 20 milligram adderalls i'll just
take those instead of
but the problem is i did it and i went i
went oh this feels too good i can't do
this
oh no no i'm sorry this is cocaine i
can't you know
[ __ ] i think you still do it because
you knew a little too much about those
time release ones you know what i'm
saying because i've never heard of them
well i i talked to my doctor sure and i
looked into it because
i said i want i want to be able to focus
and i
and i go i go it's five answers because
you can't out d on it and i go
is it bad for you and he goes it's all
bad for you it speeds your heart up it's
speed well it's a form of math i was
like oh
okay sometimes i would take like an
adderall like the
time release one and then like an energy
drink before the gym and like my heart
will be like
i can feel my heart pumping i can see
colors i can take like it's insane
i don't like to come down off admiral no
it's the worst headache right that's
awesome i don't get headache you're just
mean it's it's not good
the time release ones like it makes me
not hungry like it make and
when i start to come down i won't eat
like i will be tired but
and i won't be able to get out of that
mood unless i jerk off and then i'm good
which is weird too much well it made me
think of it because
i'm talking so have you how much have
you what's the most you've done about it
all
uh 20 milligrams i wouldn't because
you're big so does that
it doesn't matter that jacks you up
though right 20. i i wouldn't do well on
it yeah
i'd just talk a lot if i was on it i
don't [ __ ] with it yeah that heart stuff
and the
i don't [ __ ] you're too old to be
doing that stuff yeah i'm not cocaine
adderall
stay away papa no way your doctor will
tell you that
[ __ ] a doctor i had a doctor say i'm
telling you when i was 40 i had a doctor
say you don't do cocaine do you go no
i'm not a coke guy
she goes okay because it's sometimes for
certain guys it's like it's spit it's
like russian roulette
you could have a compromise in your
aorta or it just enlarges your heart and
you're [ __ ]
if you need a doctor to tell you that
you're an idiot dude i was doing blow
off her tits that's
itchin that's it all right kids um
next dates for me tacoma washington july
29th 31st tacoma
washington tacoma comedy club north
carolina
august 19th through 21st la jolla comedy
store tickets just one on sale
kids and that's a friday saturday sunday
la jolla california
friday saturday two shows friday two
show saturday one show sunday right now
those tickets will sell out they just
went on sale today
get tickets at f a tkz.com then i have
san jose improv on there san antonio the
big boy september 24th
25th bunch of other dates on there get
tickets at fatkz.com
come see me in ontario california
improv july 29th 30th 31st
i'm going down to august 4th i'm going
down to american comedy club
comedy company in san diego and i'm
doing one show
um and that's on a wednesday august 4th
so come check it out
and then i'm going to be at the houston
texas houston texas
improv august 19 20 21 come to papa
get your tickets we're gonna have some
fun there we are kids
that's it kids new studio vibes love you
we're out